COLT MCANLIS: Inspirtation's
a funny thing.
I mean, there you are
idly going about your day,
eating a banana, and boom, some
amazing revelation hits you.
How fitting is it that all
of the technological advances
we've had over the
past 40 years have
been because of these
sort of crazy, amazing
inspirational thoughts.
Take Burrows-Wheeler
Transform, for example.
It's a very common
compression algorithm
for Linux and the web.
But even the authors
themselves will
admit that they don't fully
understand how they came up
with the algorithm itself.
Huh, that's the trick with
inspiration, I suppose.
You get greatness
from nothingness.
But it doesn't really
help you if you
want to implement
the algorithm itself.
But fear not, young programmer.
I'm here to help.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
this is "Compressor Head."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of funny things
about information theory
is that whole "theory" part.
See, there's some
interesting points
about the theory that don't
always work out right.
Take entropy, for
example, which generally
measures the information content
of a data set given in bits.
But one of the
issues with entropy
is that it fails to
take into account
the order of the symbols.
See, regardless of how
I shuffle this data set
of 0 through 9 here, it will
always have an entropy of 4.
But if you've been watching
the rest of our shows,
you know that order
does, in fact, matter.
Take delta coding, for example.
If we have this variation
of our data set,
we can see that the
delta-encoded version really
doesn't provide us
with any lower entropy.
However, if we sort
this data set, giving us
the nice linear number
range from 0 to 9,
the delta-encoded version
produces a much lower entropy
than the source stream.
Now, in an ideal world,
we'd be able to just
apply this type of
sort to all of our data
and end up with a perfectly
compressible stream.
That's not actually
how it works.
See, pure sorts are
generally one directional.
That is, once you sort
it, you can't get it back
in its original order without
a whole ton of extra data
to tell you where
everything goes.
So we can't purely sort
it, but we can get close.
See, the Burrows-Wheeler
transform, or BWT,
will shuffle around the
data to cluster together
groups of the same symbol
as much as it possibly can.
The benefit of this is that once
the symbols have been clustered
together, they effectively
have an ordering, which
can make it more compressible
for other algorithms
that can take advantage of it.
Now, remember, this isn't a
perfect sorting algorithm.
It's more of a rough
clustering algorithm.
Well, technically, it's a
lexographical permutation.
You know what?
Anyhow, the point is that BWT
has one amazing characteristic.
We can encode to
and decode from BWT
without having to add any
significant additional data
to our stream.
Let's take a look.
Go!
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Whoa!
COLT MCANLIS: We
want him talking?
The Transform part of
Burrows-Wheeler Transform
starts by creating a table
of shifted permutations
for your input stream.
So let's take the word
"banana" as an example
and write that in the
first row of our table.
Now, on each row under that,
let's do a rotational shift
of that word to the
right one character.
That is, all of the letters in
our string shift to the right,
and the front-most character
gets pushed onto the back.
We do this for each symbol
in our stream, rotating one
character to the
right, so we end up
with a table whose
number of rows
equals the length of the stream.
The next step is to sort
the rows of this table
lexographically, giving
us a sorted table form.
Now, this is where some
of the dark magic happens.
You can see that each
row is effectively
a permutation of
the word "banana,"
but also, each column is
a permutation as well.
The first column, of course,
is the sorted permutation
of our word.
But really, what we want is
the last column, in general.
This N-N-B-A-A-A has some
interesting characteristics.
Notice it's got better
symbol clustering
than any of the other columns,
especially our input stream
and, thus, is what we
output as our encode.
Now, before you run off,
there's one other piece of data
that we need to grab as well.
Notice that in our sorted
table, the input string
actually sits at index 4.
We'll need this row index
during the decode phase
of the Burrows-Wheeler
Transform,
because it will allow
us to move from our more
compressible permutation
back to the source string.
Now, you may ask yourself, why
do we choose this last column?
I mean, the one right
next to it seems
just as good, seems to
have very close clustering.
Why not that one?
Well, this is more BWT magic.
See, this last column has
an interesting feature.
If we have only
this, N-N-B-A-A-A,
we can recover the rest of
our sorted table entirely.
The other columns don't possess
the same characteristic,
which is highly
important when we're
trying to invert our transform.
Banana.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's great!
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
The remarkable thing about
Burrows-Wheeler Transform
is not that it generates a
more compressible output--
any ordinary sort
would do that--
but that this
particular transform is
reversible with
minimal data overhead.
And to help us demonstrate that
is my good friend Magnus, who,
turns out, is training for the
World Sorting Championship.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah!
Sorting is my thing.
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
This guy right here, he's
going to take it all.
All right.
So at the start of
our decode step,
we're given the string
N-N-B-A-A-A and the row index
of 4.
If you recall, N-N-B-A-A-A
represents the last column
of our table.
So Magnus, can you put an
N-N-B-A-A-A up on the board
for us?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Like that?
COLT MCANLIS: Just like that.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Great!
COLT MCANLIS: DO it.
Now, when he's
doing this, I want
you to watch his technique.
Watch the way his hand
flows through the process.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah!
Finished.
COLT MCANLIS: Fantastic.
Yeah.
Young kids, you're
afraid of this guy.
Now, once we have this
data in our table,
the next step is to sort it,
which is where Magnus comes in
for us.
All right, Magus, you ready?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Absolutely.
COLT MCANLIS: We're
going to do a sort.
Nice warm up.
Don't pull anything.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: OK.
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
When you're ready, go.
Excellent, good job.
Great form, nice.
Remember, clench those abs.
Yeah, good, stay with it.
Fantastic.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: All right!
Ha ha.
COLT MCANLIS: This kid's good.
All right.
Now that we've got
a sorted table,
the next step is to prepend
the input string again.
So Magnus, another
N-N-B-A-A-A, please.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Over there?
COLT MCANLIS: Right there.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Great, man.
COLT MCANLIS: This guy
kind gets it, right?
Good.
Nice.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Ah!
COLT MCANLIS: Now-- all right.
Now that it's there, we've
got to do another sort.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: A sort?
COLT MCANLIS: Another sort.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: OK.
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
Now, I'm going to time this one.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: OK.
COLT MCANLIS: This is going
to be a good warm up round?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
Ready?
When you're ready,
three, two, one, go.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: OK.
Let's go.
COLT MCANLIS: Now,
remember, you've
got to tighten your
abs during the sort.
You're going to be judged
on speed and accuracy here.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Boom!
COLT MCANLIS: Fantastic.
Look at that.
11 seconds.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah!
COLT MCANLIS: That's a
personal best for this guy.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Wow!
COLT MCANLIS: You're
already sorting faster
than Michael Phelps.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That's great to know.
COLT MCANLIS: I agree.
So this is how the
BWT decode works.
We append our input string
across the rows of our input
table, then sort,
and then continue on
until we've recovered
our original matrix.
So Magnus, ready
for the big one?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah!
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
So here's what
we're going to do.
OK?
We're going to do
this four more times--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Four?
COLT MCANLIS: --so we've
got six letters in each row.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Wow!
COLT MCANLIS: You
think you can do it?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah!
COLT MCANLIS: Are
you ready to do it?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: I'm
ready, ready, ready!
COLT MCANLIS: This is for
the World Championship!
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah, man!
Let's do it!
COLT MCANLIS: Ready?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah!
COLT MCANLIS: Set, go!
All right.
Good.
Great.
Good job.
N-N-B-A-A-A. We're going to
get you so many endorsements.
You're almost there, Magnus.
Finish strong!
Ah!
Oh-oh-oh.
Man.
Great job, kid.
All right, all right, all right.
Calm down.
Why don't you hit
the showers, and I'll
walk the people through the rest
of the algorithm, all right?
Good job today.
Good job.
I don't think he's got
a shot at that one.
Anyhow, thanks to Magnus, we've
got a recreated permutation
table alongside
a nifty row index
that we output during
the encoding phase.
Since this matrix over
there is identical
to the post-sorted
one from the encoder,
the fourth row actually contains
the original input string,
"BANANA."
See?
Pretty easy stuff.
Oh, and to be clear,
kids, training
to be a world
champion at sorting
requires a lot of
practice and dedication.
So eat your vegetables and
listen to your parents.
MALE SPEAKER: Take one.
COLT MCANLIS: How do you
make your hair do that?
MALE SPEAKER: Lots
and lots of gel.
COLT MCANLIS: Really?
I'm gel-ous, and not
just because it's a pun.
Nice.
It'll take him a second.
In 1994, Mike Burrows
and David Wheeler
were set up to be the title
fight at the second annual UFC
championship in
Las Vegas, Nevada.
But before the fight,
while playing a few rounds
of pai gow, the two
ended up creating
the Burrows-Wheeler
Transform algorithm.
MIKE BURROWS: That
isn't really true.
COLT MCANLIS: No, no.
No, it is not.
Um-- ha.
You know, one of the problems
about working at Google
is you can't really
throw a stone around here
without hitting the inventor
of some amazing algorithm.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I want to introduce you
to the co-inventor of the
Burrows-Wheeler Transform, Mr.
Mike Burrows.
Mike, it's fantastic to see you.
Maybe if you have
a second, can you
sit down and talk to us a
little bit about your algorithm?
MIKE BURROWS: Certainly.
I'd like to put you straight
about that title fight.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
So I guess at the beginning,
let's start there.
MIKE BURROWS: Well, it really
started with David Wheeler.
He was on the faculty of
the University of Cambridge,
but on sabbatical at Bell Labs,
and working on compression.
And he came up with
the algorithm there.
I only learned
about it some years
later when I became
his graduate student.
COLT MCANLIS: In the
world of data compression,
Burrows-Wheeler Transform
just stands alone
against everything else.
There's nothing really like it.
How did you all come up with it?
MIKE BURROWS:
Well, I asked David
what was going through his
mind when he came up with it
originally.
And he didn't know.
He could not explain
to me how he came up
with that particular algorithm.
I got the impression that
he was playing around
with sorting the
contexts of characters
that were to be encoded and
using that as a good predictor.
And then he must
have realized that it
was possible to invert that
sort under certain conditions.
COLT MCANLIS: Did you and Mike
kind of co-create the article
together?
Was it more of his idea,
and he handed it off to you?
How did that relationship work?
MIKE BURROWS: What
happened was that he never
bothered writing it up.
I learned about it from
him as a graduate student.
And the years ticked
by after that.
And he never wrote it up.
At the time when
I was a student,
I thought that it was
just one of those things
that grad students learn.
And then eventually, I realized,
no, this was really special,
and the world ought
to know about it.
When he did it, he did not think
of it as a practical algorithm.
He thought of it as
an algorithm to use
to calibrate other algorithms.
It wasn't practical for
him, because he didn't have
a really fast implementation.
And computers at the time
were significantly slower.
And so it didn't
really go fast enough.
So I decided that what I should
do is write it up myself.
And in order to do that,
I had to do something.
And so I worked with
him to make it go fast.
And we came up with ways to
implement it efficiently.
COLT MCANLIS: So
I've got to ask you,
in the 20 years since this
algorithm's invention, what
has been the most amazing thing
you've seen it applied for?
I mean, it's been everywhere,
from the Linux operating system
to a protocol on the internet.
What's impressed you so
much about its use so far?
MIKE BURROWS: Well, I suppose
the most unexpected thing has
been its use in DNA sequencing.
It puts together
the fragments of DNA
that have been sequenced
independently very efficiently
into a combined whole.
But there have been many
other advances around it,
particularly in ways to do
the sorting efficiently, also
variance of the transform,
one that sorts only
limited-length contexts.
It turns out that Michael
Schindler of the Technical
University of Vienna discovered
that if you sort the context up
to any finite
length k, it's still
invertible as a transform.
Unfortunately, the inversion
takes twice as long,
so it's not popular.
But it still works.
David Scott and Yossi
[? Azah ?] managed
to find a bijective variant
of the transform, where
the size of the
transform string is
exactly the same as the
size of the input string.
COLT MCANLIS: So you don't
need the row index at the end?
MIKE BURROWS: Yes,
that's correct.
It's a bit more involved
and a bit slower
to do the compression,
but it still works.
And that was another
surprise for me.
COLT MCANLIS: Give me a
little bit of background here.
Where did you actually publish
the paper originally for this?
MIKE BURROWS: There's a
funny story about that.
We first of all sent the paper
to the Annual Data Compression
Conference.
But they rejected it.
And there were no comments
about why they rejected it.
So I wrote to them and asked
why they had rejected it.
And they told me that it was
their policy not to explain
why they rejected papers.
So we just published it
as a technical report.
The next year, people
at the same conference
actually asked me to
submit the paper again so
that they could publish it.
And I said, no.
And I wasn't really
going to explain why,
because it was my policy not
to explain that sort of thing.
So the algorithm actually
became more well known
when someone else who
saw the technical report
published a popular
article about it
in "Dr. Dobb's Journal."
So that was the first
real publication where
people got to know about it.
COLT MCANLIS: Wow.
So just completely bypassed
the academic route,
and go for mainstream media.
That's how we get our
algorithms out nowadays, right?
MIKE BURROWS: That's
the way it worked.
COLT MCANIS: Listen,
Mike, thank you
so much for coming on
and talking to us a bit
about this algorithm.
We're really honored
to have you here.
MIKE BURROWS: It's a
pleasure to be here.
I felt, given the state of
the other "Compressor Head"
episodes, that I ought to
come along personally and fix
things.
COLT MCANLIS: Huh.
OK.
Well, thank you for that.
You sure did.
MIKE BURROWS: Thank you.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
Oh, it's on me.
Oh.
I was just texting my boss.
So it's apparent that
BWT doesn't actually
compress the data, it
just transforms it.
To practically use
BWT, we need some way
to apply another
transform that's going
to yield a stream
which has lower entropy
and, thus, is more compressible.
Good old delta
compression doesn't really
help us that much.
Encoding our post-BWT stream
of N-N-B-A-A-A yields us
the version of the
string, this whole thing,
which has an entropy of 1.77,
while the source entropy itself
is only 1.45.
We haven't actually
improved anything.
No, for this type of data,
we need a different type
of transform which is better
suited for the type of symbol
clustering that BWT produces.
We call this
move-to-front encoding.
Effectively, start by
creating a buffer that
contains all unique symbols
that your stream could have
and list them in a sorted order.
For our purposes, we'll just
use the English alphabet.
The move-to-front
algorithm is pretty simple.
For each symbol we read,
we write its output buffer
position and then move it
to the front of our buffer.
For example, if we
input the letter N,
that sits at position 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12,
13, 14.
So we write that to
our output stream.
The next step is how the
algorithm gets its name.
Once we've written
its out position,
we then move that symbol
to the front of the buffer.
Time to read in the next
symbol, which is also
N. Since that's already at
the front of our stream,
we write a 1 to
the output stream.
This is the trick
of the transform.
The idea is that since BWT
clusters symbols together,
there's a high probability
that subsequent copies
of that symbol will
appear in the stream
after we've encountered
the first one.
So we end up outputting
more 1's as a result.
Let's take a look at
the rest of the coding.
Let's read B onto the stream.
And as such, we
output the index 3,
because that's where
it sits in the buffer.
And move it to the front.
We next read A and
output the index of 3
again, since here
it sits once more.
Just fix that.
Now, the next two
A's that we read
from the stream won't adjust
any part of the buffer
since A already sits
in the first position.
As such, we simply admit
1's to the output stream.
Now, after encoding, the output
stream here is 14, 1, 3, 3 1,
1, whose entropy is 1.45, which
is identical to our source
input stream.
Eh, pretty good.
From here, you can simply throw
the output of move-to-front
to any statistical
compressor, like Huffman
or arithmetic compression.
In fact, bzip2, the popular
Linux compression application,
couples Burrows-Wheeler
Transform plus move-to-front
plus arithmetic compression
for its exact algorithm.
You're looking at
the inner workings
of science here, folks.
[GIBBERISH]
MIKE BURROWS: That's an
interesting thing to say.
COLT MCANLIS: Like, that was
just really cool to hear.
MIKE BURROWS: Yeah.
Anyway--
COLT MCANLIS: All
right, all right.
Yeah, sorry.
We could do this all day.
What's amazing about
Burrows-Wheeler Transform
is that it stands alone as
a compression algorithm.
LZ, Huffman, arithmetic--
they all have tons of variance
and have been worked on by
tons of different people.
In the last 20 years,
Burrows-Wheeler Transform
has gotten much less attention.
But that doesn't mean
it's any less useful.
In recent competitions to
compress human DNA sequences,
BWT-based compressors were
all in the top 10 finalists.
And as far as the
compression world goes,
there's still plenty left
to improve upon here.
But that's a topic
for a different show.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]